[Music]
[Music]
hey
how you doing mark how are you because
you're in hollywood how are you doing
i'm great can i get in
can get him
look at your feet they're terrible
they're so filthy
you blow my face any shade i've got
water caught the entitlement
let me see your
face
you look good
any window up please are you trying to
kill yourself of course darling
i'm dying
oops
no no don't do
that that's mine i'll buy you a water
let me tell you my story i'll get your
water blow my nose
gotta throw it out
i'm afraid i might catch from you
catch wyatt
catch the flu i had coved did you yeah i
got out is that is that why i haven't
seen you for a while yeah i almost died
i had a heart attack no does that right
now mm-hmm 4 11 p.m
hey who'd you prefer i can't master
rachel's out
i'm sorry kate moss or
naomi campbell
i'm freaking off i like them both
you're right they're both beautiful
they're both beautiful beautiful
who's the most beautiful
i think name is more beautiful honestly
i liked uh christie chillington
yeah she's your type mine um
i'm freaking moss and um karen mulder
elinda evangelista i i hate her she's
basically you know what i mean like
i love her but you know
i prefer
this new model her name is antonio
antonia
you're her antonia
she's going to be a real
girl antonia hi my name is rebecca what
are you doing how are you doing mark i'm
doing good bmw it's you i'm worried
about i'm so oh yeah of course
[Music]
is this where you eat oh no i never eat
here yes you do
you didn't die i've seen you like passed
out on the street here ciao
welcome to west berlin
going to eastbound
welcome to skid row welcome to skid row
my name is rebecca olson
i'm i'm trying to run for mayor
help me i want to be the mayor of skid
row you should be the mayor i should be
the mayor honestly i think i really
represent you know the multicultural
diversity of the tide you know what i
mean
first kind of like latino i mean i'm
black but you know first mystery
squirrels really do it
the only girl is the only chinese out
here i'm the only one
you know i know my girl uh miss italy
you seen her
miss ellie you should look like guys
but then i lost it the wind blew it away
you're endlessly entertaining and you're
divinely magnificent you're so good at
what you do
i'm not going to know more about you
honestly you can turn the radio on yeah
i'll do an interview with me i wanna do
an interview with you can i interview
you go ahead okay
hey mark tell me real quick um what do
you do
what do you do i do i document
i i don't know i i it's like
i facilitate
[Music]
who's your favorite photographer
dennis monarchy who's your favorite
artist who who's favorite artist
oh jeez that's that's like a medicaid or
ashley olsen
medicaid or ashley olsen
you can pick one pick one please say it
again medicaid or ashley i don't even
know the difference between these two
girls oh i'll tell you one is blonde one
is a brunette they're not i think
they're not the same at
much
hold on
treasure
interview
what the what's that poking out of your
skirt it's my dick
you got one you got me yes it is
i thought it was a turtle is that a
charles it's not it's a chicken it's a
rubber chicken for a snake um go get
your cigarettes it's not warm hey hey
put that away okay you got your
underwear can i put that cap on no no no
that's my tiger's cap
that's
blasphemous okay give me a second sorry
it's too hot
let's take a break
you don't want a cigarette i do but like
honestly i need to melt out of this uh
what can i do for you no just entertain
me i'm sorry can i get your room for the
night give me a song can i get you a
room at the continental please do but
play with songs
right here
you would know what to do with the room
you're probably kicked out of there oh
no i've never been kicked out of my life
i could tell
my mom once
that's when of course you why
what would you think what do you need
right now
water cigarettes i need a song can you
send me something here my friend daario
by uh
whatever your phone i bought your phone
i got mugged i got stolen
here's what really happened you passed
out on the street and lost it you know i
know i got the ghost stone and i swear
this guy stole it from me you saw my
personality
[Music]
i think there's a there's a portion of
my audience rebecca that wants to know
more about you
i think there's a whole lot of people
that fall in love with you
okay
[Music]
you gotta come to my place and edit all
night let's do that no i'd love to
so my sister said you like mary kay
i'm like
well i wish i was like youtube
oh honey i wish i could talk to you
you're hungry
kind of i'm sorry are you
[Music]
gorilla tacos no i want to go to a
burger king or jack-in-the-box oh come
on really yeah
[Music]
you want to go across the bridge
take a ride
thank you very much
you're very bossy
what do you want molly uh oh yeah i'm a
molly i did a bump last night my
girlfriend hooked me up i was at the red
line just give me a bump real quick
right outside of the key
i know
i love her here's my friend bella
she's real bad
you know i love bella honey honestly i
like you just doing everything but
honestly my favorite model right now is
kalahari
like model
kendall jenner
club i'd love to but i have no idea
oh i used to know the owners
you'd be fun with a strip club and you
got skills you'd be fun anyway really
i'm really funny yeah you know i used to
be a pull-down serum
yeah well no i'm a stripper the thing
with the pole is i know i got these
names
and chef
i'm like a model
things
one bad [ __ ] here got to go
[Applause]
honestly you're like my god
hey you like sarah jessica parker
i love her i want to be the next pair
just for parker
would you say i look like once you say i
look like a mexican
badger back in the car
you actually look like cat stevens back
in 1977. i love that
it was like eric roberts back in the
days i love him honestly
yeah he's uh is he emma robertson's dad
puppet greenwich village
one of my favorite ones granite village
soho
[Music]
my name is
what's your last name one bad [ __ ]
you've got to go olsen no it's not yes
it is really it is
eeny meeny miny it's a huge problem by
the way what's your given first name
do you love that was it
carmen
olsen
lies my name is rebecca olsen
it doesn't hold my birth certificate it
really does
unfortunately i was born in moscow
russia
i like how your outfit matches your wig
this is my favorite song of all time
[Music]
you know i'd get nothing done
you got no wisdom honey honey honestly
i'll be your secretary of your health
i'm your pr
mhm
my uh my dad shoot my mom was a
secretary
you know what her name was what was that
her name was maybe
you say
daddy
[Music]
ah
[Music]
you'll never be as beautiful as me
but
botox bimbo bad truth you'll never be
supposed to be
you'll never be a woman
[Music]
you lived in new york before i did yeah
how did you know
laurie's side
[Music]
and then my daughter just moved to new
york you have a daughter what's your
name olivia olivia i would have been her
name she moved there to the model
amazing olympia what do you think
just over
okay it's okay for good vibes
i love applebees you do i'm for choice
you don't seem like an apple juice kind
of girl i'm a chase
what would be that what would be the
remedy for
that i mean
wild child and they played the song um
four girls walking downstairs
this girl from l.a right from hollywood
her dad comes to a virginia boarding
school because she jumps from a a cliff
or whatever i'm so
i'm so tempted to just take you home and
lock you in my place and never ever let
you go
but i think you're more like a tasmanian
you could be a kid
yawn so over it you would win and you'd
destroy my place i never would i've
never ever trashed a room in my life i
have a reputation for always being like
polite about it
i respect property
from the hotel room
maybe just go
i'm thinking i'm taking your jack in the
[Music]
i'm really into older guys i kind of
call you daddy but
i don't know the first new friends not
the first time honestly i'm sick of it
oh
that's so bad
i mean this whole [ __ ] um where
they're gonna cut a coke
[ __ ] no one's [ __ ] anymore you're on
grindr
what'd you say i used to be on grinder
i don't think i do grinder
what is grinder i know i know what it is
i didn't app for uh
hook up flip for gay guys right
i'm trying men
only and how wild is it
pretty welcome
[Music]
i can only imagine
how would it work with you
you put your head on grinder what would
happen it's on an odd you put your face
there
uh
send me two shots send me a shot
honestly you got me five minutes or less
i'm sensing a conversation
really really rich [ __ ]
oh you're rich
i [ __ ] like spending
a [ __ ] powder bag
i went clubbing and then i lost it all
and then i'm gonna have to move in a
hotel
uh
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is what i did
hey girl i love your hair
now with that
see uh you know what you look like
you know candy bird's daughter
you're well you're like
i love you honey
where do you fire baby
i'd like to order a jumbo jack
cheeseburger
no mushrooms a bacon ultimate
cheeseburger
with curly fries and a dr pepper what's
this
uh large
yes um
two egg rolls
okay some onion rings and some churros
you got that
everything else no thank you
what's our total please
1978 i like a girl i can eat
i'm a real
you know my sister uh my oldest girl
she used to be uh exactly
she fat you know
she died at bolivia
like karen carpenter korea yeah
so you're going to stay out all night
dress dress like that that's all i do
well
it gets really cold at night
like low 40s high 30s
and you have no
[Music]
[Music]
hello steven
stephen klein
i love you steven
happy birthday stephen klein
congratulations happy 52nd birthday you
don't look a day over 20 honey
it's birthday no stephen calling
photographer
yeah good for him yeah i love him
honestly he's good he's honestly like
he's my best photographer
that you just want to work with
he's a great one you know you want the
grade
didn't you say your last name was
bouvier at one point yes how did you
know
i'm trying to figure out who you are man
i don't know what i'm not a max
figure me out
you know doesn't go by
it's a
what is that what's my thing
[Music]
[Music]
special
where am i taking you
take me home
you want to take me please stay with me
i need you right now i need you
stay with me
i'll be your slave
i'll wash your feet
please
can i get your room i need you to stay
with
me i'll beat you
probably let's go
[Music]
which one's your favorite
i think the scarecrow i hate come on
bye
[Music]
you